the health minister jillian keegan is
here good morning it's a lot for people
um to take in are we already too late
though to stop this virus this uh
variant i should say well i mean clearly
we've got some cases in the country but
we have acted as quickly as we could
possibly could i mean we found out
actually i think we're the first country
to find out and we we acted straight
away but this is the nature of this you
know we're working internationally but
you know normally when you find a
variant you know the reality is it
exists already um obviously now what
we've got we've got the five cases here
they're doing you know contact tracing
on the ground uh to make sure that you
know we isolate people who've been in
contact with those cases but of course
we've been here before you know this is
a variant that's here and all the
measures we're putting in place are
because we don't underestimate
new variants you said five cases i mean
what do we know how many cases we've got
we've got five here's six in scotland as
of this morning but you know i'm sure
that will rise i mean where are the five
cases the five cases i think they start
i'm in london yeah there's a couple in
london camden and wandsworth in london
um then there's one in chelmsford
brentwood uh area um and uh yeah
another couple as well um okay i think
in nottingham as well nottingham yes
actually they were the first two
nottingham and uh the brentwood area jay
biden said there's no cause of panic
are we in danger of overreacting well
we're trying to get that balance in
proportion um and it is difficult
because it's unknown so we need to buy
some time so our scientists can work
with the world's leading scientists to
just basically sort of figure out what
we know it's very transmissible by
looking at the but we don't know you
know whether it will work with the
vaccine the vaccine will work all the
other treatments etc so the scientists
do need some time for that um we think
we've got the balanced and proportional
response to it but we will review it in
three weeks that'll give the scientists
enough time to hopefully give us some
insights then we're gonna be chatting to
willie watch actually in a short time
and he is not at all happy yes and
that's why we're trying to get the
balance right with the with the uh with
the variant obviously we put some more
countries on the red list but you know
we're not doing some things which would
potentially you know shut travel down
altogether we're very much trying to
keep uh things going keep you know keep
people traveling etc but of course we
have put a few more restrictions in
place and you know how long that red
list will stay in place well they are
reviewed every three weeks so the red
list is always reviewed every three
weeks and so we'll continue to because
of course there are quite a lot of cases
in europe but you're not thinking of
adding them to the red list as well
again that will be continually looked at
it will be looked at all the time and
obviously if you get some flare up in
cases then you know then we can take
immediate action if we need to so what
about in the meantime what about the
booster
what's going to happen to uh when uh
when is everybody going to be able to
have a booster if they want well they're
working on the plan right now um so
obviously we took the jc vi advice uh
the nhs are working on opera
operationalizing that so in the next
couple of days that will come out the
booking systems etc
you'll be get you'll be contacted by
your gp that's usually the first step um
but we'll be releasing that the next
couple of days we'll have the opera the
plan and i'm pretty sure it will go in
age order again so we'll do the top age
groups you know the older people first i
mean obviously most of the old people
we've done 17 million booster jazz and
you say old people i've had
yeah i've had my boosters so steady on
uh but by the end of the week everyone
will know when they can have a booster
well the next i think probably will
happen is the next cohort will be
invited forward and then they'll be
given uh you know some some time frames
so you know but within the next couple
of months we are pretty good at this
that you know we are standing up these
these operations so we do know what to
do but we just need to give the nhs a
bit time to operationalize
you know the new because we we're
doubling the eligible people more or
less who are who are due a booster now
so how tricky is that going to be given
that
already we have i think at two and a
half million boosters a week something
like that you want to do another million
boosters yeah a week have you got enough
staff
well we've used in the past you know nhs
staff obviously the community nursing
staff of
the pharmacies the gps volunteers
retired doctors and nurses we've used
that pool of staff in the past so i
guess they're going to be looking at
which of those they need to um you know
bring back into you're going to mobilize
an army of um of nhs people yeah i mean
you know there's a lot of i mean i don't
know you know lots of lots of uh in my
case we had lots of retired doctors and
nurses we had lots of uh community
volunteers as well who had first aid
training so we did have a lot of that in
the first and they'll get the call up
again well they'll look at what they
need to do um but you know we do have
you know the facilities we do have the
people and we do have the vaccine so
they'll just be putting the plan
together to see what's what's going to
make most sense what's going to optimize
do we know this vaccine's of any use
whatsoever against this variant
i mean obviously it will be of some use
what we don't know is is is how this
will put you know we need the scientists
to look at that that's again a couple of
weeks the scientists have said they need
a couple of weeks to do all the testing
um of this against you know all the
various vaccines that we have plus the
vaccines plus the boosters but of course
the very very best thing you can do is
come forward get your first jab if you
haven't had it second jab if you haven't
had it and your booster when you're due
could be that we're completely
overreacting
had either overreact than under react at
this point i think we've been here so
many uh times that uh you know we've got
this fantastic wall of vaccine now we
want to keep that we want to strengthen
it
to you know we'd rather be stronger um
to be able to you know face any new
variants and i think we have all the
things you know we have all the
capability to do that so that's what
we'd rather do um
the clinically vulnerable are being
asked to come forward again could we
then could they find themselves in a
position where they're going to have to
be jabbed every three months
i i haven't heard that um but i think
you know clearly the clinically
vulnerable are the people that you want
to make sure have um as much of the
protection as possible okay how will we
know
if we've come into contact with an
omicron variant
how will we personally know well you
probably only know from the pcr test
that's the other reason the pcr test
omicron though do we
um we we would know the pcr test is
where they do they send that off for the
genome sequencing that's where you find
out if you know but not involved not all
of the um
labs that it's sent to are able to find
out about whether it's omicron or not at
this stage the the genome sequencing is
the second so they then go to the labs
and then they send them off to the labs
so i'm not 100 sure what that process is
going to be but the the reason we've
introduced pcr tests for travelers is
because we want to get that for genome
sequencing yeah but my point is you know
you could have come back um you could
have had your uh test uh it would be
positive you would have found out within
48 hours then i'm guessing i don't know
who who is it who is it test and trace
who would then say to me you've been in
contact with somebody for well you have
to isolate anyway right so if you if
you've tested i would positively so how
would i know whether i need whether i'd
come into contact with somebody who'd
had omicron
how would you know if you've been in
contact with somebody who's who's been
how quickly would i know that i had been
in contact with someone who'd got
omicron i could have seen hundreds more
people before you you found out that
i've been in touch and then before you
knew well they're doing that right now
right in camden in wandsworth they're
going around figuring out everybody that
these cases have been in contact with
and they get it so it's the contact test
track you know the test and trace system
which is getting all your contacts
finding out who you've seen where you've
been so you know that's the manual
process trace scheme only picks up half
of cases doesn't it
where have you got that figure that's
that's uh nhs biggest
in terms of uh half of the cases that
are um
test and trace only picks up half of
cases and that all the testing that the
labs do cannot all pick up omikron they
don't all do we don't substitute every
piece we don't send every pcr test for
genome sequencing i would imagine now
they're going to be sending a lot of
those pcr tests for genome things
because we've got a new variant but in
terms of
now
the intention now is everybody that
those people have been in contact with
they will be contacting each one of them
so you know but we're going around the
houses to say that it's going to take a
long time to find out whether somebody's
got omicron and then you contact
somebody else and then before you know
it it's spread everywhere well that's
why we're asking people to isolate you
know that's why we're asking people to
isolate until they get a result and then
if they get a positive result then
obviously they'll look into that result
more
clearly that will that will obviously go
for for testing
that's why we're asking people to do pcr
so if it's positive it can be genome
sequenced it can be checked so that's
the i mean the processes will be put in
place now but that's the sequence of
events and we can do that we can do that
so that we can follow you know the the
test now obviously it gets to be
different i mean we've seen this before
with delta wrote and all the people that
are in contact with you if you've you've
got it will then all have to
self-isolate as well so that would be
six people or so in the studio right now
um
before you know we've got another
pandemic on our hands haven't we
well obviously what we don't know right
now is how fast this is going to
transmit and whether or how you know
what our wall of defense how how well
it's going to hold up that's why we need
that's why we're putting these
precautious measures in place that's why
we're reintroducing masks and we're
asking people to be more cautious we're
putting the pcr test and day two so that
we can you know we can get that data but
yeah right now we are being cautious
we'll know more in three weeks and of
course the key thing is but you
acknowledge there could be some level of
pandemic like we saw i think it really i
think it really depends what the
scientists say about our wall of defense
about how well the vaccines work you
know there's a lot of things we need to
wait for them to come up with the
answers to that but i mean clearly we
know we've been through every every
variant of this i mean excuse the pump
you know we've been through every kind
of i think there are a few more coming
yeah well possibly but we've been
through all of this in the past right
we've had to have you know
pandemics we've you know we've had we've
had to isolate people a lot you know
we're trying now to use all of the tools
is we could find ourselves in that
position at christmas time people are
having to suffer we're in a much better
position because of but you're not
vaccinating so you're self-isolated
aren't you so yes
in a position where you can't see your
family at christmas no we're very very
much hoping that we can keep christmas
on track you know we're asking people to
isolate if they test positive with a pcr
test after they come back so they have
to well isolate until you get your
result basically that's what we're
asking people to do but of course um
you know we need a couple of weeks just
to work out how virulent it's going to
be and most importantly how well the
vaccines work but we are in a much
different position than any of the other
variants because we do have many many
many more people vaccinating if i've
come into contact with you and you've
got it i have to self-isolate don't i
yes okay so we could find ourselves in a
position at christmas where you can't
see your family
well you obviously you could be it's
isolating over christmas you could be um
but what we're hoping is that you know
we keep these cases obviously
everybody's going to be contacted people
start the isolation
with or without this you could be
isolated
for christmas you know with with another
variant you could your boss the health
secretary said christmas was on track
and it was all going to be fabulous well
of course of course christmas is on
track and actually what everyone would
be there what everybody wants for
christmas is if you haven't had your
first job come and get it if you haven't
have your second job come and get it and
if you haven't already booster come and
get it when you're asked that's all we
want for christmas and everybody contact
with somebody who's got omicron you
might be saying well today it's the same
if you have any variant today you know
if you are positive today then you
actually it's not right to say that then
you see
well i mean
you you there will be some people who
will have to be isolating over christmas
there always was you know if you have a
positive test then you isolate you know
we've got um you know the the some
politicians isolated at the moment but
if you come into contact with people uh
you don't have to have selfish yes
but now you're saying you do with the
omicron variant so all i'm saying to you
is we've fight we can find ourselves in
a position where christmas is ruined
again hopefully not and it's you know
we've got five so let's be proportional
and balanced as we're trying to be we've
got five cases today
that will go up i'm pretty sure but you
know what what we're trying to do is
really clamp down on that as much as
possible obviously put in these
departure at these these other tests
and limit the number of people who are
in that situation i get it and i
certainly wouldn't want to be in your
position or indeed the health
secretary's position but all i'm saying
to you is as of this morning given that
we have to self-isolate now if we come
into contact with somebody who's got
omicron then we won't be able to see our
loved ones at christmas
um
well the chance of that right now is is
pretty low right we've got five five
cases in the but that is that'll behave
sensibly as we've said to everybody you
know we're reintroducing masks we're
trying to you know
trying to delay you know the spread of
it so that we can buy the time for the
scientists to be able to
give us some facts really on on how well
we're protected with what we've done
already so that's what we're trying to
do and we're basically saying come
forward get your job get your boosters
the boosters will help we think they
will help um and we're just trying to to
you know to deal with this unknown at
the moment we very much hope that we uh
you know we have a christmas this year
you know we've had a an awful experience
last year um and it you know it is it is
unfortunate timing from that perspective
but you know we very much hope keep your
christmas plans in place but of course
we will have to deal with it as you know
as the scientists um you know get more
information to us we'll have to deal
with what they tell us okay we're out of
time sadly but it's good to talk to you
as always thank you very much thank you
for joining us